béla réthy er in münchen bilder die
menschen in aller welt haben immer noch
die bilder dieses zusammenbruchs von
christian eriksen vor augen welche tage
gehen dir welche gedanken gehen die drei
tage nach diesem spiel durch den kopf in
erster linie die gedanken das ist
christian jährige wieder gut geht also
verhältnismäßig guten umständen in
welche gut ja wurde gehört dass ich bin
als krankenhaus bestellt hat dass er
kontakt zu seinen mitspielern dann dass
dieser dramatische situation sich
irgendwie aufgelöst hat zumindest den in
den wohl gefallen muss natürlich genau
untersuchen was er jetzt aber die
erleichterung überwiegt die war ja ich
habe am nächsten tag schon da also ich
weiß nicht genau wie man hätte
weiterarbeiten können bei der em war
schlimmeres passiert wäre und ich bin da
schon also sagen schon wieder zufrieden
mit dem wie es weitergeht
du hast kurz danach gesagt wähler in all
den jahren meines berufslebens war dass
meine bisher schwierigste die
emotionalste übertragen
wie lange hast du gebraucht doch wir
schauen gleich noch mal kurz in ein paar
bilder reihen wie lange hast du
gebraucht um wirklich zu realisieren zu
verstehen was da eigentlich gerade
passiert das ist ein schleichender
prozess also sie zunächst mal dass ein
spieler auf dem boden liegt ohne
gegnerische einwirkung und das kann
immer mal passieren und dann nach
einigen sekunden haben sich die spieler
spezielle kapitän simon kjaer oder
thomas die linie von borussia dortmund
umgedreht und ganz ganz hektisch die
betreuung gerufen und die ärzte dann
griff einer in das gesicht von ericsson
versucht offenbar die zunge zu lösen
dabei allmählich klar dass sie etwas
dramatisches tut dann kamen die ärzte
auf dem platz da habe ich ein
defibrillator gesehen und da hat sich
das langsam entschlossen dass wir sicher
dass ein mensch auf dem platz gerade
unternehmen könnten wir schon einmal
kurz rein dramatische sekunden
dramatische bilder
[Applaus]
oder muss eine behandelt werden
schiedsrichter wie betreuung die praxis
tätig sind
der dann schwer angeschlagen zu sein
scheint
kein seiner sogar ohnmächtig ist
möglicherweise die zunge verschluckt es
wurde von minute zu minute emotionale
habeler hast du hinterher gesagt ja weil
er sich herausgestellt hat also ich
meine die regie der hat man noch
vorwürfe wahr dass sie zu realistisch
gewesen sei oder die wir vor der
situation erstmal überrascht es gab
einmal eine ganz kurze einstellung des
gesichts des liegenden christian ehring
sind da bin ich auch ein bisschen
zusammengezuckt aber der hat man sofort
weggeschnitten
es war ein herantasten an die situation
aber so was hat man natürlich noch nie
erlebt das war dann klar als man
erkennen grund dahinter dem spalier der
spieler das heißt druckmassage ausgeübt
wird
dass er wieder belebt werden muss
offensichtlich also und das live zu
begleiten ist natürlich ein wahnsinn und
ich habe mich dann eben auch
entschlossen das ist einfach nur mal
wirken zu lassen oder einfach nichts
mehr zu sagen weil was soll man dazu
sagen kommentierte situation ja nicht
live also dann ist man doch kein
reporter ist aber noch mensch und kann
nur hoffen beten und das beste wünschen
da wollte ich will euro spekulieren was
es war am ende hat sich heraus gestellt
war ja in einer herzstillstand also als
der arzt zu ericsson kam das wussten wir
alles zudem zeigen und nicht an den opel
und als der mediziner bereits bei ihm
waren setzt da erst die atmung aus also
dieses dieses herantasten bilder hast du
gerade beschrieben haben einmal rein in
deine originalkommentar zeigen nur einen
kurzen ausschnitt daraus aber einmal um
zu verstehen was da auch menschlich
passiert ist an diesem abend in
kopenhagen
der krieg ertrug massagen
herzdruckmassagen und deshalb stehen
sich die spiele davor dass man diese
bilder nicht wahnsinn grausame bekommt
er wird also wiederbelebungs wassereis
herzdruckmassagen
und die zuschauer spüren dass hier
freuen wird
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und sieh mich an dieser stelle einfach
nichts weiter sagen sondern nur hoffen
das ist alles ein gutes ende
wieder es hat nach allem was wir bisher
wissen eine einigermaßen gutes ende
genommen
du hast gerade die kritik angesprochen
die auf kam
wo verläuft eigentlich genau diese
grenze die hat sich einleben abend diese
frage hat sich ja wirklich gestellt
die grenze zwischen
dokumentationspflicht und voyeurismus
muss sein oft diese grenze dies wird
individuell empfunden also möglichst
weit hinausgeschoben wird die sage
möglichst diskret möglichst wenig es
gibt eine gewisse informationspflicht
natürlich war der live irgendwo
geschehen ist möglichst große
diskussionen keine fantasiere reißt den
geschehen sein könnte sondern nur mit
wenigen oder gar keinen worten einfach
die bilder einfach mal begleiten und die
leute einfach mal informieren die hat
auch wissen wollen was da passiert ohne
voyeurismus defensive regie also ich
habe natürlich auch teile der kritik
verstanden aber da muss ich dann den
rechtsschutz neben der selber wieder
situation erstmal neu konfrontiert war
und so bald als er gemerkt hat was sich
da abspielt hat er nur im prinzip sehr
viele zuschauer gezeigt und eher
dokumentarisch halb total und die
gesichter von von von spielern gezeigt
die direkt beteiligt waren habe ich mir
das vorgestellt haben eine wand gebaut
oder spalier gebildet um die behandlung
nicht zu sehen
die grenze ist schwer definierbar sie
stößt hat irgendwo an die ethischen
grenzen aber wo verläuft die und ich
denke wir sind also das ist nur ein
gefühl ich habe ja gerade noch einmal
selbst gesehen möglichst behutsam mit
der situation umgegangen und danach
sehen wir auch dann raus aus dem aus dem
programm und hat eine studio geschaltet
das ist kann man nur subjektiv
bewerten wie man jeweils empfindet
solche bilder eine exzellente
journalistin ulrike herrmann ist bei uns
die gesagt hat was am samstag passiert
ist hat mich sehr beeindruckt und
vermutlich hat sich auch jemand
sozusagen diese frage gestellt wo
verläuft genau diese grenze also wo gibt
es die dokumentationspflicht und wo
beginnt das juristisch zu werden ja aber
ich glaube das ist gut gelungen und wenn
also man kriegt ja denn wenn man das
sieht und das eindrucksvolle ist ja das
ist tatsächlich das ist ja ganz selten
eigentlich gelungen ist dass alle
gleichzeitig das richtige gemacht haben
also die die mitspieler haben sofort
verstanden was passiert ist die
mediziner sind sofort aufs feld gelaufen
die mitspieler am sofort dieses berlin
gebildet und was ja noch nicht das
gezeigt wurde aber was ja auch
eindrucksvoll war dann dieser wechselte
sagen der fans also als die fenstern
verstanden haben worum es geht das sie
dann aufgehört haben noch fußball
spielen zu wollen sondern oder zugucken
sondern dass sie dann eriksson besuchen
haben das ja das ein wahnsinn wie haben
sie das empfunden berlin als als wie
haben sie das empfunden als als jemand
der sich über viele viele andere dinge
und auch über fragen medien und so
weiter viele gedanken macht also für
mich war es eine der emotionalsten
situationen die ich in den letzten
jahren vom fernsehschirm und und bei
einem fußballspiel erlebt habe
es wir sehen so viel tod und leid auf
der welt aber ist wenn es live passiert
ist es etwas anderes und es ist passiert
ich habe nur gesehen wie ericsson liegt
und ich wollte wissen warum die
fernsehapparate geben mir die
möglichkeit ich habe zurückgespult und
habe dann gesehen dass er aus hingehen
umkippt und habe sofort gewusst weil ich
mit solchen dingen schon oft zu tun
hatte in meiner karriere dass er einfach
ohnmächtig geworden ist dann sofort
gewusst was los ist und als ich dann sah
wie welche hektik
stand muss ich sagen hab ich ich habe
geweint vorm fernseher wir haben uns
festgehalten mit meiner frau ich habe
gewusst dass der junge unseren leben
kämpft und für mich wäre es für uns war
es undenkbar unabhängig davon ob er es
überlebt oder nicht dass man weiter
spielen könnte
und ich finde diesen vorwurf machen aber
es ist die zweite frage die sich stellt
also dass du dieses milliarden spektakel
fußball plötzlich rückt das ganz ganz
weit in den hintergrund plötzlich kämpft
ein junger mensch einfach um sein um
sein nacktes leben
und dann stellt sich plötzlich die frage
doch wieder welche rolle spielt dieses
milliarden spektakel im hintergrund dann
kommt diese entscheidung weiter zu
spielen weil die richtig war die falsch
also für mich war sie abgrundtief falsch
die uefa hätte eingreifen müssen und
sagen müssen
hier geht es heute nicht und auch nicht
morgen mit am 12 irgendwie spiel hätte
man mal verschieden können die jungs mal
zwei drei tage nachdenken können aber am
nächsten tag oder jetzt das ist
respektlos aber diese diese
respektlosigkeit dem einzelnen menschen
gegenüber die ihr leben wir überall wir
haben eben vorher ein bisschen
diskutiert wir leben in einer welt wo
leid und tod überall passiert und wir
machen trotzdem weiter
wir brauchen ja bloß den nachrichten
anzuschalten und sehen jeden tag was
passiert aber wir machen weiter
egal ob wir in kriegsgebiete schauen und
dort war schon hin liefern ob wir
unseren lebens auf unser lebensstil dazu
beiträgt dass woanders menschen sterben
das wissen wir und wir machen trotzdem
weiter also das hat mich nicht
überrascht dass es weitergeht
das hat mit dem fußball nicht exklusiv
aber es war natürlich vom persönlichen
erleben her
ungeheuerlich also nicht ich konnte
nicht mehr zu gucken und ich habe
verstanden aber gerade daniel
engelbrecht aus dem augenwinkel gesehen
als diese bilder liefern engelbrecht sie
haben nicht wirklich hingeguckt gerade
ich habe schon oft angeguckt ich habe
mir an dem gleichen tag in der gleichen
nacht angeguckt am nächsten tag und ich
hab sie von zitiert als als diese bilder
zum ersten mal zu sehen waren ich hatte
am ganzen körper gänsehaut ich habe ja
immer mit panikattacken zu kämpfen
seitdem mir das passiert ist und in dem
moment war alles wieder da und alles so
schlimm was ist dann was passiert bei
ihnen auf dem platz 2013 glaube ich war
das ne 2013 im juli genau ich habe mich
ähnlich wie bei ericsson also selbst
meine szene die ist einfach identisch
genau seine abgelaufen wenn man wir
haben die bilder eben gesehen vielleicht
kommt das ja noch einmal kurz zu spielen
aus der regie was war das für ein spiel
bei dem das passiert ist dass ich sie
erste songspiel den stuttgarter kickers
gegen rot weiß erfurt und man sieht auch
mich liegt an der außenlinie werten
einwurf und ich bin zu meinem mitspieler
gelaufen und wollte den ball haben und
sagt dann in mich zusammen und als ich
die szenen von ericsson gesehen habe es
ist kurios aber der erste schritt von wo
er seine koordination verloren hat dabei
mir da kam mir sofort in den sinn
oh mein gott bitte nicht so genau im
nächsten moment liegt er auf dem boden
und in dem moment hat es bei mir im
ganzen körper herab und ich habe
angefangen zu zittern ich habe gänsehaut
gekriegt und ich habe mir nur die ganze
zeit gesagt bitte schnell wieder
aufstehe wieder aufstehe wieder auf und
als seine frau später noch eingeblendet
wurde habe ich mir gedacht dieses gefühl
von seiner frau und seine seine kinder
ich glaube der sohnes 3 und der andere
ist glaube ich 1 der dreijährige krieg
das gerade mit wieder papa leblos auf
dem auf dem boden liegt und das ist
einfach eine unvorstellbares gefühl
diese hilflosigkeit die ähren dem moment
gespürt hat sie damals in der situation
realisiert man dass da jetzt etwas
existenzielles passiert dass das dass es
wirklich um leben und tod geht versteht
man das in dem moment absolut nicht also
wenn es jetzt auf meine situation
beziehe ich bin danach aufgestanden und
hab gesagt ich spiele weiter
ist alles okay deswegen kann ich mich
nur anschließen dass man spiel danach
fortsetzt ist für mich absolut
unverständlich weil ein christian
eriksen der da mehrere minuten mehrmals
hat man eine halbe stunde stunde um sein
leben kämpft der ist danach nicht in der
lage die entscheidung zu treffen spielt
weiter das war nicht so schlimm und
deswegen ist es für mich nicht
nachvollziehbar weil er kann diese
tragweite einfach noch nicht einschätzen
selbst jetzt ist es noch so dass jetzt
kommt diese spannende situation was ist
denn nun passiert und warum ist jetzt
zusammengebrochen weil
es ist schön dass er wieder wohlauf ist
und dass er wach geworden ist aber jetzt
kommt halt drauf andrea aus dieser
geschichte herauskommt
reden wir gleich noch darüber noch
einmal kurz in ihre situation sie sagten
gerade sie sehen zusammengebrochen
wieder auf gestand und weitergespielt
genau ich bin zusammengebrochen und nach
15 20 sekunden der bewusstlosigkeit bin
ich wieder zu mir gekommen und habe
gesagt ja gut kann weiterspielen
und ohne personen genau ich bin nach 15
20 sekunden wieder zu mir gekommen aber
es waren herzstillstand ja es war ein
herzstillstand ich war weg frei für eine
rhythmusstörung mit einer
herzrhythmusstörung genau die dann
diesen herzlich und verursacht hatten
und nach zehn minuten hat mich der
trainer ausgewechselt und ich habe ihn
gefragt sagt obwohl es mich raus da
sagst du bist nicht mehr normal gelaufen
du bist getorkelt und später habe ich
die szenen dann selber im fernsehen
gesehen und hab dann gedacht was ist
denn da passiert
das war für mich ungewöhnlich was haben
die ärzte dann festgestellt wie es
weiter erst mal nichts erst mal wurde es
als kreislaufzusammenbruch hingestellt
oder als hitzeschlag holz an dem tag
sehr warm war und sei alleine war julie
julia und zwei wochen später ist es mir
ähnlich ergangen ich habe über diesen
moment diesmal erkannt als meine beine
angefangen haben zu zittern als mir
langsam schwindelig wurde als die leute
um strom nicht mehr gehört und nicht
mehr gesehen habe und wusste machst du
jetzt weiter recht so wieder zusammen
und dann habe ich meinem trainer gesagt
hey ich muss sofort raus und dann kam
die notärzte auf dem platz an mein puls
gefühlt und haben gesagt der schiffen
lebensgefahr wir müssen sofort ins
krankenhaus und dann wurde es
festgestellt dass ich eine verschleppte
es muss grenzen hatte schleppte
herzmuskelentzündung genau sie haben
diese verschleppte erz muskelentzündung
und gehen auf den platz auch an dem tag
an diesem zwanzigster juli und fühlen
sich bestens in guter verfassung an
diesem tag beim ersten zusammenwirken
zwanzigster julia ich habe mich super
gefühlt
der zusammenbruch ist auch in der 70
minute so ich habe mich in der form
meines lebens gefüllt und von das ist
das tückische dabei ist kommt von jetzt
auf gleich bei christian eriksen hat man
es ihm vorher auch nicht angesehen und
von jetzt auf gleich wird er einfach so
der schalter ausgeknipst
wie ging es dann weiter sehen glaube ich
fünfmal danach operiert worden habe ich
das richtig erinnere sechsmal bis ich
dann meine karriere beenden
ok viermal bis ich dann wieder meine
karriere fortgesetzt habe mit
implantation des defibrillators das
heißt der der defibrillator der wurde
implantiert des der ist dafür da
sozusagen einzugreifen für den fall dass
der herzrhythmus irgendwann wieder aus
dem takt gerät genau dass dafür da dass
er mein herz überwacht und dass es im
worst case wieder auf null setzen würde
wenn ihr herz rhythmusstörungen
einsetzen und ich in lebensgefahr
schwebe dann würde der defibrillator
sich einschalten und nicht dann retten
und den habe ich eingesetzt bekommen
weil das war die absolute voraussetzung
dafür dass wenn ich wieder spielen
wollen würde und das wollte ich um jeden
preis haben sie auch gemacht dann
weltweit schlagzeilen gemacht als profi
fußballer der mit defibrillator wieder
auf dem platz stand der auch tore
geschossen hat wir haben die szene
damals auch gezeigt werden ein
großartiges spiel wunderbares tor
gemacht aber nichtsdestotrotz sie ahnen
so ein bisschen abschließend gefragt was
auf christian eriksen jetzt zu kommt
definitiv also ich sag ja nochmals ich
bin froh dass er wieder wach geworden
ist und wir sind alle froh dass er
wohlauf ist und jetzt die ersten grüße
aus dem krankenhaus geschickt hat aber
jetzt kommt wirklich die interessante
und spannende frage wie kommt er aus
dieser geschichte raus trägt er
bleibende schäden davon kann er jemals
wieder zu 100 prozent gesund werden oder
sein und der fußball ist ja wirklich
ganz ganz hinten an gestellt also ich
bin schon froh dass das seine familie
jetzt wenigstens in diesem zustand sehen
kann dass er wieder wach geworden ist
und hoffe natürlich dass er da auch
gesund wieder raus kommt das heißt die
frage ob der jemals wieder weiter spielt
die steht noch völlig offen wird ich
weiß auch bei ihnen damals wurde geguckt
gibt es eine genetische disposition in
der familie war es wirklich nur unter
anführungszeichen diese
herzmuskelentzündung also dass sich die
dinge in dem man jetzt so langsam
langsam mühsam herausfinden was genau
also dass wenn er diese wenn das nicht
als rhythmusstörung war es kann ja auch
nur vermuten ich habe ja auch nur die
bilder gesehen
dann müsste man natürlich jetzt schauen
wo kommen die herzrhythmusstörung her wo
sitzt der hut wo die ausgelöst werden
und kann man die eventuell veröden oder
verizon um das so zu eliminieren dass er
wieder normales leben führen kann ohne
herzrhythmusstörungen ohne gefahr zu
laufen dass er plötzlich wieder
zusammenbricht und das dauert also das
ist jetzt ich rechne nicht damit dass er
in
diesem jahr noch mal fußball spielen
oder sind schwierige operationen ich
habe ich habe das gelesen teilweise bei
bei bei vollem bewusstsein wird wird
geguckt wo an welcher stelle wird genau
diese rhythmusstörung ausgelöst und so
weiter das heißt abschließend noch
einmal gefragt diese panikattacken die
angst dass da wieder irgendwas ist mit
dem herzen
das haben sie bis heute das kommt den
extremen situationen immer mal wieder
vor diese atemnot dieser dieses ständige
prüfen über beim herz oder der puls dass
man immer guckt ist alles in ordnung war
irgendwas bin ich jetzt mal trainieren
und es ist eine außergewöhnliche extreme
übung dann gucke ich danach ist alles in
ordnung und sobald ich einen schlag
schmerz spüre denn nicht im takt ist und
dann geht es erst mal los dass ich denke
okay jetzt erstmal durch bleibt ruhig
alles okay du hast jetzt seitdem du
aufgehört das keine probleme mehr gehabt
also macht jetzt keine sorgen
béla réthy gefragt bilder was weißt du
über den zustand jetzt von christian
eriksen und zwei dingen wie geht's
weiter für diese identische mannschaft
in diesem turnier auch die frage ist ist
das ein spiel das man werden kann
am selben abend so unter dem eindruck
dessen was da passiert jetzt einfach
weiter zu spielen
welche konsequenzen wird all das haben
zunächst von der wertung wird vermutlich
keine der mannschaft geht entsprechende
der trainer hat mehrfach geäußert dass
jeder unter diesem einfluss steht aber
natürlich auch immer wieder kontakt zu
christian eriksen hat sie wollen jetzt
eine art trotzreaktion zeigen und sich
dann gegen belgien noch mal zeigen und
einfach für ihren mitspieler
weitermachen
sie ist jetzt zuerst bei den ersten
meldungen an dem tag als das passiert
ist dass eric sind per facetime mit den
mit den kollegen in der kabine
kommuniziert hätte und darum gebeten
hätte dass man weiter spielt aber
normalerweise kann man die verantwortung
weder wissen sondern auch den
mitspielern überlassen
da muss der verband entscheiden dass das
eben nicht geht so in der dänische wurde
eins drüber
die uefa es gibt genug möglichkeiten
vielleicht zwei drei tage später am
spieltag eben diese partie nachgeholt zu
haben aber das wurde
daneben anders entschieden und die
wertungen dieses spiels wird ja die wird
weiterbestehen man musste darauf als
kommentator oder irgendwie foto
fußballspiel zu übertragen
wahrscheinlich nicht absurden war also
man muss natürlich auch irgendeine form
auch die finden würde gehen die
überraschend bei ihrer ersten teilnahme
dieses spiel geworden haben aber darum
darum ging es am ende überhaupt nicht
sondern dass dieser tage eben
irgendeiner form halbwegs versöhnlich zu
ende ging
aber das spiel wird gewertet der der
trainer hat hinterher gesagt die spieler
waren in einem schockzustand wir hätten
nicht spielen sollen
das ist mein gefühl vielleicht hätten
wir einfach in den bus steigen sollen
es war eine schwierige entscheidung und
es war falsch für mich dass die spieler
das am ende entschieden haben siehst du
genauso
ich glaube dass erweckt hat also genauso
frage gegen angela jetzt wird alles gut
weder siehst du genauso entschuldigen
ehefrau sind sie dran erklärt ja ja die
spieler absolut entscheidende sei aber
das entscheidende bindeglied war der der
kapitän
sieben okay er der wohl gesagt haben
sowie spielt auf keinen fall weiter so
lange wie nie konkrete informationen
haben wie es kristian geht oder dass wir
kontakt zu ihm haben
und als er dann kontakt zu zum
christensen hatte war er auch der gesagt
hat doch gewisse dann doch bereit zu
spielen aber das ist man man kann da
natürlich nicht ganz normal rausgehen
und fußball spielen also das wird die
situation hatten haben sie natürlich
unterschätzt die haben diesem wunsch
tieres mitspieler ist einfach genommen
ohne natürlich rational darüber
nachzudenken was sie eigentlich tun und
das ist auch nicht die aufgabe in so
einem moment von von von mama von
spieler immer weniger angst haben
müssten darum dass sie einen kollegen
heute in vielen fällen einen guten
freund verliert die wickler eine klare
situationen erkennen und das müssen die
verbände machen hätten die verbände
gemacht haben müssen so also immer nur
ganz kurz und abschließend zu dem
komplex mich erinnert das auch an die
geschichte mit dem bus attentat auf die
mannschaft von dortmund also was diese
entscheidungen angehen dann fragt sie
warum lernen wie eigentlich nichts aus
solchen situationen ja dass das ist
dieses beispiel aber ich würde gerne
noch mal ganz kurz
ich weiß nicht warum nicht draus lernen
ja eben gesagt es gibt
man muss dazu sagen und ich habe mich
nochmal vergewissert ich habe mit
professoren wenig kenne von seinem paul
ii der beim dfb und überall aus
flensburg mich noch mehr gewissheit ich
habe mit solchen dingen schon öfters zu
tun aber es gibt ja verschiedene gründe
warum es zu einem herzstillstand kommt
was sie gerade gesagt haben dass man
etwas verwirrt da geht es um gefäß
anomalien es gibt so ein wolf parkinson
syndrom mit dem ich selbst zu tun hatte
als trainer in teneriffa wo ein spieler
aus südafrika hat sich nicht dieses
syndrom hatte wo es zu einer
unnatürlichen schnellen reizleitung
kommt durch das herz was dann verödet
werden muss weil es sonst zu flimmern
kommt aber es gibt auch andere gründe
es gibt ja es ist kardiomyopathie das
herz und natürlich vergrößert ist und
dadurch die herzmuskulatur schwer
vereinbar ist
es gibt aber auch das problem mit
herzmuskelentzündungen das ist du sagst
verschleppt der herzmuskel sind
eigentlich verschleppte entzündungen
eine also eine infektion im körper und
viele spieler dass das haben wir als
trainer ganz früh gelernt wenn jemand
die bahn ja immer weitermachen ich bin
krank ich trainiere ich genauso lange
war und dass er und dann bekommst du
eine das ist eine verschleppte
entzündung
das heißt ein abwehrsystem ist unten
aber bevor das deinen körper und das
greift den herzmuskel an dann kommt es
aufgrund der einer verschleppten
entzündung zu einer herzmuskelentzündung
die dann wiederum so wie es verstanden
das kammerflimmern auslösen kann wie das
kammerflimmern über deutet dass du die
dollars schläger art noch um das herz
das gehirn nicht mehr versorgt wird und
du sofort und gibt also es gibt
verschiedene gründe
das muss man herausfinden was dahinter
steckt aber im sport haben wir vor
einigen jahren verschwanden jahren damit
angefangen dass verpflichtend zu machen
das gab es früher gar nicht also du
musst eine forderung die die lizenz für
die laufende saison bekommst musst du
diese herz unter druck machen eigentlich
auch schon seit jahren wirklich das geht
so viel geld in den fußball rein und
wenn man da noch ein bisschen mehr rein
stecken würde dann würden solche fälle
deutlich weniger werden und das ist für
mich bis heute wirklich nicht
nachvollziehbar